[Music]
a neighborhood has been cleared out or
is in the process of being cleared out
after a real estate company bought out
the area for a new project now it's just
west of I-15 and Sahara not too far from
the Palace Station actually Victoria
Saha gives us a closer look at what may
be next
demolition has already started for many
homes in this neighborhood by Richfield
and Milo way this new project by the
Fisher Brothers has families searching
for a new place to live
what was once a neighborhood with dozens
of ranch style homes is now boarded up
and fenced off as the Fisher Brothers
company dives into a new project
the Clark County Assessor's website
shows dozens of homes owned by the
company I spoke to a resident who did
not want to be identified but he says he
was living in one of those homes now
fenced up before he was told to leave
earlier this summer they only gave us
like two months to get out I was like
what the heck like you know I mean like
at least wasn't even over or any of that
the resident tells me he still had four
months left on his lease but the company
moved him to another rental property
having kids everything you got to find a
place to live not too far from this new
project stands Area 15 also owned by the
Fisher Brothers on their website they
describe owning 75 Acres off the Las
Vegas Strip which consists of industrial
office and residential space in an email
to 8 news now they say they plan to turn
the space into over 1300 Apartments
ranging from Studio to three bedrooms
retail options office space and open
space for dining and walking tenants say
whatever may come out of this project
they hope it was worth the hassle of
having them move out out reporting near
15 in Sahara Victoria Saha 8 News Now